[Musique]
les fleurs palissent le feu s'éteindre
l'ombre se glisse dans le jardin
l'horloge tisse des entraînant je crois
en tant que le temps
le vent ma porte des bruits lointaines
Guetta ma porte j’écoute ton vin et
l'âge plus rien
plus rien ne vient
[Musique]
j'attends des
oiseaux
qui s'enfuit viens chercher
n'oublie
dans son lit le
temps pensez-vous
[Musique]
que le silence
et pour le temps
j'attendrai dans le tour
[Musique]
reviens bien vite
les gens sont froids et sans limite les
nuits sans toi comme ton se quitte on
oublie tout
mes revenus et si
doux immatrices un peu émouvoir
avec tendresse revienne à ce mois
et dans tes bras
tout René ton
[Musique]
avis j'attendrai